and many years later
these individuals who took their parents
advice and didn't did not pursue was in
their heart end up many years later
hating their parents because
they are stuck in a dinner job one of
the things that could be closer to death
without dying is having to get up every
morning
and go to a job you hate
give me some overarching spikely legend
wisdom on what's a good way to think
about
creativity from your perspective in your
journey not only you and how you do it
but others you've admired and meant
through the last 40 years that you're
like oh that's her process oh that's his
process what should be the thought
process or some hypotheses of how to get
there and be successful at it
well i want to thank you gary vee for
lobbing a big fat one a big fat juicy
fastball you're winning you're
softball
right down the little plate
and i i for
i'm in my fourth decade as a filmmaker
and i speak
all the time at universities and in
colleges and one of the things i always
try try to strive
i try to hit home
is that over the years
over the decades
parents have killed
more dreams
i'm gonna repeat
that parents have killed more dreams
anybody
and this is specifically when we come to
the arts
parents can understand
what you why you go to med school why go
to business school
but when it comes to the art
many parents
have no understanding
how to become an actor
a dancer a riot a porter a poet a
painter
whatever it is the arts is some type of
mystical thing
and
and parents want the best for their
children a hundred percent and they
think in their wisdom
they could give the vice
to
[Music]
their children nothing
want to do with the traditional
work thing
do you think your parents do you think
do you think yeah
and a lot of times
knowing
how parents might have took a second
mortgage on the house and whatnot and
done everything
so you can go to
a great undergrad school and the bills
and these student loans are crazy
and so there comes that parental
pressure
and also guilt knowing that
what our parents have done
and many years later these individuals
who took their parents advice and did
not pursue
was in their heart
end up many years later hating their
parents
because
they are stuck
in a den and job
because
one of the things that could be
closer to death without dying
is having to get up every morning
and go to a job you hate
let's talk about that strategy and i
think i want to highlight gary what you
did with v friends and um which has been
massively successful for those of you
who don't know um right now there was
one that was auctioned for as high as
1.2 million uh and the lowest current
value of it is of one is 30k
so what did you do to bring branding and
generate over 91 million dollars in the
first 90 days and then i do want to come
back to blockchain but i want to start
with some of those strategies well the
thing that is most fascinating to me
about the blockchain and one and a lot
of my friends reached out to me when i
went so hard and they're like man i've
watched you for 15 years leave so much
money on the table to preserve your
reputation why are you ruining it now
basically is what they were saying
you're doing something so high risk and
i'm and i said to them said you don't
understand the blockchain it's actually
the reverse
if you are the creator of a project an
nft project you're actually more in
control than anything that has ever
happened before let me explain with
vfriends first i use the utility of the
smart contract to create a three-year
promise contract of a conference called
v-con that i'm doing at u.s bank stadium
in minnesota in may
which you know it's it's a profound
lineup of every of the who's michael's
even coming and i don't think he's ever
been to minnesota and so like you know
it's you know it is cold there i am
aware thank you um
the you know and so
first i think people are not using the
utility aspect of nfts enough right now
right now we're in the art and
collectible phase no different than the
internet 94 we were in the information
age right the internet's awesome for
information the internet was awesome for
information it was also going to do so
many more things in our society the
blockchain right now is on art and
collectibles but it's a contract and so
i did a three-year conference i did a
lot of access tokens um where zooms like
information things that people actually
value besides the collectible
but the part that i was referring to
earlier and this is why i wanted to be
in business you know candy's really the
only other major thing i'm really
involved in
is that i knew how
michael thought about the consumer let
me just paint the picture for everybody
who's hesitant to do an nft project
because they actually are good people
and they fear that the value goes down
with with
candy with me friends if god forbid the
market crashes and so you know it's one
thing for all the people that spent two
thousand dollars for it last may and are
selling it for 30 40 70 100 000. they
did great but what about the guy or girl
who bought it today for 40 000 and the
market goes to 8 000. for me
because it's on the blockchain i can
provide more value for that person
you're the central bank you're the
country you're in control so i just you
know i've been telling a lot of my
friends who i think have
not the best behavior in mind who are
going to be like well they made it you
know they bought it they took a risk i'm
like it works a little bit different
you're in control of that economy and
your reputation is completely tied in so
i think for the people that have good
intent
and have resources and are smart for me
i take a lot of usd off the table with
my project
and put it in one place just for the
rainy day so i can deploy that capital
back to the people that own v friends
and i think the best projects will do
that gary hi hi again um my name is
burkhan firstly i [ __ ] love you
you're a legend um and secondly my um my
question relates to tick-tock you kind
of spoke about it a little bit towards
the end there but i was already in the
line and it was too late to change my
mind and not ask the question so here we
go um strategies in terms of tick tock i
am a sales coach currently
and i want to start posting more on tick
tok i do instagram and facebook already
what do you recommend i would do i would
do 10 things the way you exactly do them
elsewhere and watch them not work
i would consume a shitload of content on
tiktok and see trends
and then i would mimic those trends in
in your interpretation for example one
of the trends on tick tock is to
actually film another phone of your
content on a different platform and talk
over it
right so you could literally take one
phone play your sales video on
on facebook and then record with another
phone and talk over and say hey kids
because you know it's younger this is
what i'm saying on facebook the version
for you to practice now is this
right you see where i'm going yeah
you have to come up you have to consume
the reason i always do well is i
listen
for hundreds of hours before i talk
it's not obvious to you because you're
only seeing the talking part
you don't see the 14 hours that i put in
in listening to tick-tock content on the
flight here
right it's the same reason i'm going to
crush sports cards this flight here
wasn't tick-tock it was sports cards
you know eventually everyone's gonna be
like how are you right about soccer and
wrestling and basketball cards it's
because i read for 14 hours the sale
prices on auctions on those categories
and then read articles and then went on
twitter and searched what people were
talking about i put in the [ __ ] work
you don't need me to give you the
strategy for tick-tock go live in
tik-tok for 100 hours and you'll figure
it out
cool thank you you got it
i view that content is the oxygen
that creates awareness around what
you're doing
so to your point if you stop creating to
do something
you in essence are turning off the
oxygen of what you're doing so the
reason i have continuously content
created even though i've gotten
remarkably busier
in my time is because i agree with that
i think once you stop creating
you become less vulnerable oprah winfrey
businesses are not as impactful today as
they were a decade ago because she
doesn't have a show
that's just real life
and so
yeah i'm a believer that at all costs as
a matter of fact one of my biggest
anxiety points professionally is that
because now v friends
is so successful in taking up my time
while i still have to run vayner x
the thing that you know
we only have so much time in the day the
biggest casualty
to the huge success that i have in nft
land is my content
i am definitely in a different output
place i mean i went seven eight years
without putting out four pieces of
content on my instagram every day and
now
i get two a day and that's like a big
day and
that adds up and so i'm i'm conscious of
that i think about that bro
tap talent
without work ethic it should it was a
wasted opportunity
you understand yeah
it's [ __ ] a wasted opportunity yeah
i just think about that [ __ ] all the
time how many people had loads of talent
that either didn't fight to find it
i'm always curious about that like who
was the greatest painter of all time
but she or he never decided to paint
gave up yeah not even gave up just
didn't even go
uh novak djokovic
when i was chopping with him
had there not been a tennis court behind
his family's
uh he never went out restaurant he would
have never gone there and instead he
would have been into skiing he's the
greatest he's gonna be when it's all
sent on the greatest male tennis player
of all time the serendipity of a tennis
court
like
i think about that [ __ ] this is why i
push curiosity so heavy like try [ __ ]
just try some [ __ ] you were [ __ ] if you
said no i don't sing and just stayed
home and played video games or whatever
you don't know what would happen i know
what would have happened all the good
[ __ ] that time last year used when the
[ __ ] happened that's why i know that
part wouldn't happen
[Music]
[Music]